that's the rat with the pizza I've seen
that oh yeah the pizza rat that's these
famous rats are disgusting - yeah
they're pretty gross you've seen that
Netflix documentary on rats yeah no oh
no really dude oh dude really yeah you
need to watch it because it's um it's
educational it's not just gross and it's
really gross but when you realize how
many of them there really are in major
cities ah yeah the biomass of them yeah
it's stunning really York's all rat it's
just just rats
this is many rat is more or somewhere in
the neighborhood of as many rats as
there are people really and there's 8
million people and there's how many more
as many or more cheese yeah just don't
think they hello I mean you see them
non-stop walking around they're just
guessing yeah obviously most of them are
subterranean most of them are living in
houses and most of them and I mean they
burrow their way into tiny little holes
how long does a rat live to question how
long does a rat live because they're
born there's a lot of them but do they
stick around for like 20 years
dude the documentary showed how they
send young rats to try out poison really
yeah the oldest rats they send them out
there because they don't know any better
they let them die they're just assholes
Wow yeah they here's a little tip if
they're ever doing construction in New
York in front of a restaurant you don't
eat it you don't need on that Street why
because they're digging it up whatever
their little ecosystem is and they're
just yeah so if they're digging up the
street they're dying somewhere else I
would imagine in New York it must be so
hard to keep them out of a restaurant oh
it's got to be so hard like I guess
maybe you leave some in the dumpster for
them like you give it to the monsters
just ahead yeah there's a girl on to the
the stakes for Kong a little shish kebab
stick your last job when you're closing
down the restaurant you litigate down
the rats are our friends put the skulls
out well what is interesting what are
those various sizes of them they mostly
go up to about two pounds
in New York City uh he doesn't think
there's any better three because they'd
be too big to be able to move around
right like a physical physiological
limit to their size does it say how long
they live average about two years one to
two years in the wild up to four if you
have it as a pet oh wow that's it yeah
hamsters like that my wife had rats for
pets when she was a kid wish Goff no she
was just a jersey kid just loved animals
and she would just ride her bike around
in this rat would just be like on her
shoulders Jesus Christ rat lady weird
but it was but she said they were super
smart and super affectionate yeah if you
had it it's a whole life and you raised
it right yeah why not yeah it's not
dirty it's not like going through the
sewers and eating poo and climbing on
your hand right but it would if you just
let it go maybe 100 percent she like had
it out with her go rat like if you just
let it let it loose in the wild how long
would it take for how long would it take
for domesticated rat to adapt to living
in like a New York City sewer 40 seconds
what do you think they would do their
crazy fucking Disney look at you from
the suburbs what he been living in a
house yeah with like you know those
multicolored rats they have like little
different colors on them are you so
clean with your pink hair oh you got
different colors look at you hey Joe get
a load of this one he's not even Greg
hey how come you any gray look at you
you're white you're brown you're like a
fucking dog over there you think you're
better than us don't you yeah hey get
over here I guess you don't know how to
get him into the restaurant do you
hungry
what do you got money on you you give us
some money we'll show you we get all the
good food you ever been a little italy--
wait till I show you a show roll the
dice getting born a rat being born a rat
oh the worst terrible